GETTING CAUGHT IN A LIE.
LISTEN.
>> THE BORDER IS SECURE.
THE BORDER, WE ARE WORKING TO
MAKE THE BORDER MORE SECURE.
THAT HAS BEEN A HISTORIC
CHALLENGE.
>> SECRETARY MAYORKAS, DO YOU
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THAT THE
BORDER IS SECURE?
>> YES, AND WE ARE WORKING DAY
IN AND DAY OUT TO ENHANCE
SECURITY, CONGRESSMAN.
>> Todd: SHERIFF, WHAT KIND OF
RECEPTION DID MAYORKAS EXPECT IN
LIGHT OF THE FACT THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS TURNED ITS
BACK ON THE BORDER AGENTS AND
LIED TO THEM?
>> YEAH, HE'S TONE DEAF LIKE THE
REST OF THIS ADMINISTRATION AND
IT IS CRAZY HOW THEY ARE DOING
AN ABOUT FACE AS IF AMERICANS
WOULD FORGET WHAT THEY SAID
BEFORE.
LOOK AT WHAT GAVIN NEWSOM IS
DOING IN CALIFORNIA.
I AM SEEING OTHER OUTLETS, LIKE
FOX REPORTING IT, CNN IS
STARTING TO REPORT IT.
NEXT TWO YEARS, THEY WILL TALK
ABOUT IT AND CLAIM, PRETEND THEY
DIDN'T SAY IT WASN'T A CRISIS
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
HE DESERVED A COLD WELCOME AND
THAT IS WHAT HE GOT, HE TURNED
HIS BACK ON THEM AND THEY SEE
HIM AS A COMPLETE COWARD.
>> Carley: SHERIFF, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION JUST FILED A
LAWSUIT AGAINST ARIZONA TO STOP
YOUR STATE FROM PUTTING UP
SHIPPING CONTAINERS TO BUILD A
MAKE-SHIFT BORDER WALL TO
CONTAIN THIS CRISIS, HOW DO YOU
FEEL ABOUT THAT TIMING?
>> WE DON'T LIKE THE TIMING.
THIS IS PAR FOR THE COURSE.
10 OR 12 YEARS AGO, WE DID
SB1070, WHICH WOULD HAVE MADE IT
ILLEGAL TO BE IN THE STATE
ILLEGALLY, AND COULD HAVE
CHARGED THEM ON A STATE CRIME.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS THERE
TO STOP US UNDER THAT UNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
WHEN A STATE TRIES TO PROTECT
THEIR COMMUNITIES, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL SWOOP IN WITH
TAXPAID LAWYERS, BY THE WAY AND
TRY TO STOP ANYTHING EFFECTIVE
WE DO IN OUR STATE.
>> Todd: HERE IS WHAT THE
LAWSUIT CLAIMS, DAMAGES FEDERAL
LAND, IMPEDES ABILITY OF FEDERAL
AGENCIES AND OFFICIALS,
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL TO PERFORM THEIR
OFFICIAL DUTIES.
LAWYERS SPEAKING HERE, YOU KNOW
WHAT IS UPON HAING, THEY WANT TO
STOP IT AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE BEST LEGAL WAY TO STOP IT.
THAT EXPLANATION IS PURE BS, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FROM
EFFORTS HERE, WANTS THE BORDER
TO BE OPEN AND THERE IS NO OTHER
CONCLUSION, IS THERE, SHERIFF?
>> NO, THERE ISN'T, THEY ALWAYS
WANT TO UNDERMINE THE RULE OF
LAW AND WE ARE FLOODED WITH WHO
KNOWS WHO?
YUMA IS GETTING -- RUSSIANS, 70
RUSSIANS PER DAY ALONG WITH
PEOPLE FROM OTHER COUNTRY, OVER
1000 A DAY IN YUMA.
EL PASO IS BEING OVERRUN.
I JUST TALKED TO ANOTHER GUY WHO
IS DOWN THERE AND SAID THERE ARE
LARGE GROUPS, ONE AFTER ANOTHER
PASSING THROUGH NEW MEXICO JUST
OUTSIDE OF MEXICO.
THIS IS CRAZY AND WILL NOT GET
BETTER.
WE WILL NOT FALL FOR THIS WE
WANTED IT SECURE THIS WHOLE
TIME, THAT IS JUST FLAT OUT LIE
AND MAYORKAS IS JUST A LIAR.
>> Carley: SIMPLE QUESTION, BUT
WHY DOES EVERYTHING RELY ON
TITLE 42 WHEN IT IS ILLEGAL TO
CROSS INTO THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
COULDN'T SOMETHING ELSE REPLACE
IT TO GET THIS SITUATION UNDER
CONTROL?
>> YOU ARE A COMMON SENSE
PERSON, I'VE BEEN ASKING THAT
FOR A LONG TIME.
IT IS ILLEGAL, WHY DO WE NEED
TITLE 42 TO USE IT TO SEND THEM
BACK?
I'M GLAD WE HAVE TITLE 42, THAT
IS ALL BORDER PATROL HAD LEFT.
WHEN YOU SEE APPREHENSIONS, LIKE
IN YUMA, 95% OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
BEING LET INTO THIS COUNTRY AND
THEY LET EVERYBODY ELSE IN, ONE
GUY THEY DIDN'T LET IN IS THE
GUY THEY SHOULD HAVE LET IN.
WE LIVE IT IN ARIZONA AND TEXAS
AND IT IS PRETTY FRUSTRATING.
>> Todd: CARLEY RAISES A GREAT
POINT, THERE IS SOMETHING IN
PLACE, IT